[Music]
[Music]
ha no you took just lost my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 30th
episode of dirty chess tricks in this
episode I am going to show you some of
the wonderful tricks in the Kings Indian
defense from the black perspective the
opening arises after the following order
d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3
Bishop to g7 now I'd grab the space in
the center with the movie 4 and
accordingly black stop the advancement
of the e-pawn with the move d6
now the first trick I want to show you
is a very high-profile trick which was
introduced by Geller in the year 1968
and amazingly enough even in the modern
era many title players are falling into
this trick so you should definitely look
out in your feeder games the gala trick
happens when white plays the ever Bach
system which happens after the following
water that is Bishop to e2 Castle on the
Kings side
Bishop to g5 Knight B to d7 Queen to d2
c6 Knight to f3 ePHI and now castle on
the Kings side instead of castle if you
open and continue here with the Moody
file then I think after night to c5
black get an important tempo as either
White has to move the Queen or give up
the bishop pair in either case black
obtained a very good position so that's
why the main move over here is castle on
the Kings side and afterwards black will
continue with the move he catches d4
Knight captures d4 and now night to c5
the trick is set right here especially
if your opponent doesn't know the theory
then he like you to play this mistake
that is f3 which looks so natural as it
protect the pawn and consolidate the
center instead of f3 why should continue
with the move either Queen to f4 or
Bishop to f3 in either case black get
comfortable middle game with a
reasonable equality but as it happens
that f3 has been tried many times even
at the highest level and just to
illustrate my point when I check this
position in online database I found out
that there are 25 games has been played
from this position with the move f3 and
you can see the results they are
tremendous for the black
ok so let's find out what's wrong with
this nation looking move
well everything looks good except there
is one problem and that is Pam hahahaha
so with this pseudo sacrifice black
immediately become pawn up and if white
is not careful then game can be decide
very quickly
for example the bad move over here is
Bishop captures d8 afterwards black can
simply take the Queen and you can see by
the arrows there are three white PCs are
hanging and white cannot save all of
them so Bishop captures d8 is straight
out of the window let's look at other
options that is what happens if you open
and capture the knight the first more I
want to consider is Knight captures
efore which looks very obvious which
protects the bishop but then comes
Knight captures efore still White has
the same problem so White has to take
this 9 and after that black will play
this Bishop captures d4 check which
forces why to capture this bishop and
now black regain his piece with the move
Queen captures g5
so after the whole sequence black become
a clear pond up and it is not advisable
for white to take the d6 pawn because of
the following problem I reached this
position against a national master where
my opponent tests my idea with the move
Queen captures d6 well after that black
initiative run down the board with the
move rook to d8 so not only black is
hitting the Queen but looking at the
juicy D 2 square so that's why wide
response is force over here but has to
defend one of the target that is Queen
to e3 and after that yep we are going to
continue with the rook to d2 attacking
the bishop my opponent played one of the
best move in this position that is Queen
to f3 not only defending the bishop but
also attacking the f7 so I have to
defend with the move Bishop to e6 but
now again black is attacking two spots
so white response is force why it has to
continue with the move B 3 and that
allow doubling the rook on the D file
and grabbing the every single initiative
my opponent decided to challenge the
default with the MU rook f.2d one but
then comes a very strong move as Phi so
black has a very simple plan Bishop to
g4 and nabbing a piece after a long
thing
my opponent come up with the move based
three but this doesn't stop anything s
after the wonderful reply Bishop
captures s three once again black
emerged with a clear point advantage the
game wrap up very quickly
my opponent played rook captures I
responded with the move Luke kept his d2
and after Queen captures Bishop rook
captures Bishop with an open King and a
clear point advantage after few moves
black easily converted the full point
last but not least what happens if you
open replace the obvious move F captures
efore we're here more or less same story
black is going to continue with the move
Bishop captures d4 check Queen captures
d4 Queen captures g5 and again if white
doesn't take the d6 pawn then he will be
point down for nothing so let's see
Queen captures d6
and now rook d8 and in this case if the
Queen goes to the c7 then rook to d7 is
a very strong reply so the force reply
over here is Queen to f4 and after that
black is going to exchange the Queen and
place the rook on the D 2 square where
it attacked the b2 doesn't matter how a
white responds for example in this game
white continue with the MU B 3 but then
comes rook to c2 attacking two spots
so why response is again force white has
to play rook to f3 but after the move
Bishop to g4 it is very clear that black
has tremendous initiative and in fact by
forcing sequence later on black managed
to win the e4 pawn and the game I have
attached the rest of the game in the PGN
which is available in the description so
kindly go through it
the second trick I want to consider in
the savage variation which arises after
the Mordor f3 well here obviously black
has to castle on the Kings side and now
why it's idea is that in the long run he
just want to play moves such as h4 g4
like a Sicilian English attack and
cramped on the Kings side ok main line
move is Bishop to e3 and after that I
have two knight moves which contains two
separate deadly tricks the first of all
I want to consider is Knight B to d7 and
after that white will obviously continue
with the move Queen to d2 so idea is to
exchange the dark square bishop and then
launch the devastation on the Kings side
no matter black should continue with the
movie file here obviously white needs to
close the center in order to execute his
attack and black should play the move fi
so not only stopping any b4 idea by wide
but later on if black wishes he can put
the knight on the C 5 square which
cannot be harassed by the b-pawn now if
you check this position in online
database the main move over here is
either Bishop to d3 or Knight to e2 in
either case black get a very comfortable
game but in few games or at least as per
my knowledge and mega database 2017
there are 10 games has been played where
White has immediately considered the
move Bishop to s6 and this is where our
trick lies as this is not an accurate
sequence as black and immediately
exploited with a wonderful blow yup
Knight captures efore boom hahaha so
same old story we are capturing the pawn
with a deadly tactics two moves are
possible and it doesn't matter however
white captures let's look at the most
critical one that is F captures efore
and after that black is going to regain
his piece with the move Queen check and
after g3 and
in captures at 6:00 yes indeed black
emerged with an extra pawn but what has
this forcing sequence that is Queen
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to be fire so trying to regain this pawn
well it's true that here it's very hard
to save the pawn but in return Black has
tremendous activity in fact if I'd
grabbed that pawn then black get a
winning position to illustrate my point
I like to show you one of my game
against a 2100 rated player we're here I
continue with a very tricky move rook to
a6 allowing him to capture the c7 pawn
afterwards rook to b6 happen so
attacking be to kindly note if Knight to
be file then the simplest is you
continue with the mood night to see file
attacking e4 and after Bishop to g2
Black has this lethal check which get
his pawn back and remain upon up
advantage so Knight to be far is not a
good choice for the white so instead why
it should continue with the move b3
which happens in the game but then comes
night to see if I attacking e4 Bishop -
G - and now the forcing moon a for
targeting the b3 squared my opponent
responded with the move rook to be one
but after pawn captures pawn captures
and the move fi black quickly get the
winning position the game continues with
the move he captures f5 Bishop captures
f5 here white cannot play rook to be two
so he decided to play rook to d1 but
after Knight check King to e2 and rook
captures be three blacks five pieces are
raining down on the lose White King and
to edit the insult he is a clear pawn up
[Music]
the second one I want to consider is
Knight to c6 which has a more attacking
potential with the movie file and
accordingly
why should continue with the move Knight
g2
- but in that case this bishop will be
in prison for a long time so what many
white players thinks that okay first let
me take out this bishop on the d3 square
and after the blacks response ePHI I can
play the move Knight G - E - and that
way my all pcs will be very active
well why it has a very good point except
there's one problem in this line and
that is Knight to g4 hahaha so black is
sacrificing the whole night and white
has to accept this for example if you
continue here with the move Bishop to g1
then after pawn captures Knight to d5
and the Moon Knight to e5 after the
whole transaction black remain a solid
point up so considering this here white
has to obviously accept this piece
sacrifice and after F captures g4 pawn
captures d4 so not only black is
regaining the material but after Knight
captures Knight captures and the MU
Castle black emerged with a clear Korn
advantage
the card trick I want to show you in the
four pond attack which arises after the
Mordor f4 castle on the Kings side and
now Knight to f3 but here my
recommendation is you should continue
with the move Knight to e6 and as per
the mainline theory why it should
continue with the move Bishop to d3 but
not everybody updated with the theory
and many times what happens is they
continue with this typical Kings Indian
move Bishop to e2 which i think is a big
time mistake because here black and
exploit the situation immediately with
the MU ePHI after F captures Aoife D
captures ePHI and the move defy black
has this wonderful resource like to see
Phi attacking twice on the e4 and White
has to do something to protect the pawn
now if you open play is the interesting
move Bishop to g5 then I have attached a
simple line in the PGN which will not
only give black a comfortable equality
but in many lines black get a slightly
better position the move which I want to
consider in this video is Queen to c2 as
if you check this position in online
database you can see over here that this
move has been played highest and as for
the situation it looks so natural before
I move on I like you to pause this video
and find out what is the problem in the
Queen to c2 line well I hope you find
this familiar pattern that is bam
ha-ha-ha
so this typical Knight captures efore
scenario where black become a clear pawn
up with a very good tactics in the mind
where here white response is force white
has to take this piece and after that
black will continue with the move Bishop
to f5 now as I have highlighted over
here white has three different choices
amongst them the knight supporting move
is a versed one for example
if white tries to support the night with
the other night let's say night f2g Phi
then the simplest is you take this night
and after night captures and Queen check
black emerge with a winning position so
that's not good let's look at the second
option what happens if you open and
continue with the move Bishop to g5 well
against this black should continue with
the MU f 6 so now there are two pieces
hanging so what response is force why it
has to take this born and after Bishop
takes Bishop takes and Queen takes black
is attacking the Queen in the database
one game continue here from Queen to c3
black responds with the move Queen to b6
so now it's impossible for white to
castle on the King side and more ever
white cannot even touch the e5 pawn in
the game he decided to continue with the
rook to have fun but this will
permanently stop y2 castle on the Kings
side black continued here with the MU fi
and it's not a pleasant scenario for the
white after long struggle black managed
to win this game in a style in case if
you are wondering what happens if you
open and take this pawn let's say Knight
captures ePHI then the idea is rook a to
e 8 and now as per the mace move by the
engine that is castle on the Queen side
black has this wonderful resource Queen
to f6 which at least NAB a piece
probably the most critical reply over
here is Bishop to d3 but after that
black response is very obvious black is
going to capture this piece and after
Bishop captures and the move fi black
get the piece back with a wonderful
attacking position here why should
obviously take this pawn and after rook
takes yes
material balance has been restored but
in return black get tremendous piece
activity now to illustrate the danger in
this position I like to show you my game
against a 2,200
player where my opponent continued with
the move Bishop to e3 attacking the
knight I responded with the movie for so
if allowed then Knight to d3 check will
happen so my opponent captured my knight
i captured his knight and now he castle
on the Kings side so already black has
tremendous initiative after the move
Queen to g5 and white has to play some
accurate moves he responded with the
move rook a to even but this nature
looking mu which grabbing the e-file
turns out is a big time mistake as after
the following sequence that is Bishop to
e5 rook to e4 and now the dazzling
sacrifice Bishop captures s2 BAM well
why does it have any good choices White
has to take this and after that Queen
check if King to G 1 then F kept his g2
is a very strong reply so in the game
White has to forcefully come forward but
such a king dance will only allow black
to have all the sort of fun as after a
few checks that is rook check King to fo
rook to g4 check King to e3 Queen check
King to d3 and after rook captures evil
white realized that he cannot capture
the rook as his Queen will be a goner
the fourth and the final trick I want to
show you in the Bishop to d3 line which
happens after the following order that
is Knight to f3 castle on the Kings side
and now to avoid the main line theory in
the modern era many player choose the
move Bishop to d3
well a fight is not interested to block
the pin then we are definitely go for it
and here the accurate response is Bishop
to g4 pinning that night the main line
will continue with the move h3 Bishop
captures f3 Queen captures f3 and after
Knight to c6 black initiative is already
running down the border here the main
move is D Phi but then White has to give
up the bishop pair after the move Knight
to e5 so not many of your opponent will
like it they will likely to continue to
protect the ball with the move Bishop to
e3 ok no issues we are going to attack
it one more time
with the move Knight to d7 now if white
wants to hang on to this central pawn
then the only response here is Knight to
e2 which in fact played 17 times and you
can see the result black has crushed
most of them so let's see what can be
the wrong in this situation before I
move on I like you to pause this video
and find out what is wrong with the move
Knight to e2 did you find it let's see
once again black has this dazzling
Knight move Knight to e5 so attacking 2
spots and even though white can take
this knife after Knight captures ePHI it
is very obvious that there is no way
white can save this bishop a sample line
can run like this
Queen to g3 Knight check King to Evan
and now the moves c5 and not only black
emerge with an extra pawn but White has
a very funny King position which will
take some time to rearrange his species
well I hope you enjoy along this
wonderful tricks in the Kings Indian
defense feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
you